you got wayne over kendrick
hell yeah really yeah wayne
yo this is the thing man it's like and
i'm my thing is
kendrick's never missed wayne's missed a
lot
missing is all subjective right not
really
but wayne's got some black eyes on this
he's got black
he does but he's got classic but so do
tupac i got a lot of
a lot of misses yeah yeah there's a lot
which is why
which is why tupac's not in my top he's
he's he's in my top 10-ish
but but like i got um i kind of put
wayne and tupac in the same tier
you put wayne over wayne is a better way
better rapper than tupac
he's a way better rapper i don't it is
people that's probably send me death
threats for that i don't give a [ __ ]
yo listen i've someone threat i said
tupac was overrated as an mc
i didn't say his music was overrated i'm
a huge poc fan yeah huge i had posters
of them on my walls
all of us did but i said that [ __ ] i
forget what interview it was
and the [ __ ] was dming my wife
threatening to kill her bro
dog she had to make her page private so
so so look so
people don't play about tupac now people
don't play about tupac but i love tupac
too but at the same time it's like
i stack people get and they feelings
about pop
right in there it's two people pock and
kobe you can't say nothing about because
people are hello kobe is one of my
favorites
i love kobe too but i'm just saying like
you know kobe fans crazy people
no they not because i'm one of them
people you're one of the people okay
okay now i want to
i'm definitely not bro i'm definitely
i'm definitely one of them people that
was buying kobe's when they was on sale
when nobody was wearing it before nobody
was wearing them yeah i was one
i actually got a pair of elite kobe's
like that because the dude at house of
hoops was like
yo you're the only person i've ever seen
body shits and wearing it here you can
get them and it was only like ten pairs
but yeah the tupac
tupac fans are very emotional they are
but like i feel like
but pack is a great artist but
see all time
it's hard to do all type because i gotta
put kanye i don't give a [ __ ] if he
ain't ready
bro and but kanye's in the class of
michael jackson yes i don't think that's
tupac's in the class
i think kanye is in class let me ask you
if you agree with this i think kanye has
the best discography
in hip-hop history [ __ ]
who's got a better discussion pop
history yes who's got a better
discography
i think the only miss was jesus's king
and i mean yeah he had some jesus king
was trash
please like this ass juice for sure he
could have went he could have went like
od traps like trapped soul meets gospel
and that would have been hard
i ran through that album once and never
touched it again kanye fan
how you messing up a clip song we ain't
gonna go there all right so look so
yeah i ain't gonna fight he might kai
anyway got it bro who else got i mean
i think i think chloe i think the
closest
is kendrick because kendrick has no but
kendrick don't have the
uh amount bro listen kendrick don't have
the amount
take out classics take away classics and
ghost faces up there too
take out classics take out the classic
word games got a nice discography
game is one of the best rappers that
will [ __ ] if i wanted somebody to rap
for 24 hours straight because i was
trying to win a prize i would go get
games
game rap all day about anything like but
all right i love gay but
bro and i i can't run away from this bro
we gotta stop playing with drake bro see
nah bro i'ma keep it listen wait wait
wait and it's hard for me it took me a
long time because
to admit to this it's hard to listen
it's hard to put as a jay-z
fan yeah it's hard to put anybody on the
same level as jay-z
drake's up there i equate drake
to the jay-z [ __ ] like this might to me
michael jordan the greatest
person that ever touched a basketball
right but
stephen stephen curry is the greatest
person to ever shoot a basketball that's
199
right that's how i equate the drake
whole [ __ ] because it's like and not
that i'm drake's the greatest hit maker
ever
but this one i'm saying but but at the
same time i don't think anyone can
perform more hits in a row than drake
you know it's the realest [ __ ] you
haven't been on a drug show of course
i only been the one and i'm kind of a
drake hater low-key like
historically i've never been a hater i
may not agree with his actions i'll say
that
i don't hate him i wouldn't say a hater
but i love him as artist i don't know
him
i just don't um but bro i went to the
summer 16 [ __ ]
i went to summer 16 it was him in the
future yep i remember that
bro and madison square garden like the
[ __ ] floating in there yeah
the that wasn't the ferrari it was like
some like balls
bro i was dead i was in the riser right
everybody's in everybody's industries in
the riser
i was standing next to charlemagne and
me and charlemagne was like
damn right then he did this [ __ ] like
you know you know how
jay used to do this [ __ ] what he used to
be like he'd play songs and cut them off
play someone's kind of off yeah
brother so i was waiting for drake to do
worse behavior i'm like oh no oh you
remember
he did that during that show he was like
ah it was like i couldn't believe it no
i couldn't believe it that's what a guy
yo he did and that was i was waiting for
worse behavior
yo he put on worse behavior and i'm and
the great thing about being in a rise is
you can see
everything right right right and i was
looking he played that [ __ ] for 15
seconds he's like not [ __ ] that turn
that [ __ ] off i was like what
yeah and and i can't remember which song
he played after that but
i was like nah bro like well that's like
on the uh the tour he did with migos
where he was running across the [ __ ]
basketball
basketball push it he was just right he
just did quick features yeah like
10 in a row and like was like i just
want to remind y'all like oh yeah
it was all but that's what i'm saying i
think like the thing is
like all right look yeah if you a j
fan and you i'm a biggie fan j
fan we also didn't mention jay's best
discography in hip-hop history which is
crazy
he's he's no but he he's probably him
and kanye
for being fair or drake but i put kind
of gets a slight edge just because of
producing he gets a slight edge
right i agree but yeah jay right like
because i was having this debate with
academics and he was telling about hits
and he was like
where i'm from is not a hit i'm like
how's it not a hit right i'm like
because bro see you and i understand how
he could say that but
but the reason why he says that is
because you in an era where 50 cent have
[ __ ] up everything with the sales [ __ ]
right
y'all equate how you interpret music
based on what it sells
so when where i didn't know what gold
the platinum even meant
at all i didn't know that it meant
selling a million when i was a kid
like think about [ __ ] dark and hell
is hot bro
i didn't know you know dark fleshing my
flesh blood on my blood so 387
000 records the first week and did not
have a single or a video i was
both in the same year both in the same
that's what i'm saying it's like
so i didn't know nothing about the sales
[ __ ] but people like
axe [ __ ] was like billboard i'm like
so you let these people have no face
their system determined what's the best
[ __ ] ever nah like you know what i mean
because i'm like yo like if jay had to
go hit for hit with somebody
he could go all day but i but one thing
i said
but drake nobody can go here for him
with drake the problem with drake is
drake
start pulling them [ __ ] from half court
like steph
you're gonna start pulling that [ __ ]
from half court yeah and i still put i
still
have in my book jay over drake of course
of course but he's
i can't i think with drake i think i
think drake
is kind of like you said how steph curry
kind of came through and it's just like
not fair with changing the game
you change the way the game's played the
change i think drake
has some things you could say about him
obviously the
the writing [ __ ] you know i also look at
the way he responded to that and
kind of like loki had meek's career in a
little chokehold for a while but
you know like and but then i look at
drake and the pusher thing and how i was
so disappointed that drake never replied
to push his [ __ ] freestyle
bro i ain't golato it's like it was like
he was in a very tough position but i
always used to say you know what i
always just say about drake i used to
before him and push i had his issues
i used to always say like he need to do
a takeover just attack everybody
he need to just make a record i always
wanted drake to make kind of like
kendrick's controllers
but he didn't kendrick didn't attack
people right but he definitely he caught
everybody out he was being nice
yeah it was it was a polite hey guys i'm
better than y'all but
but i i really feel like i don't know
kendrick but i really feel like kendrick
believed that nobody could [ __ ] with him
i think that still nobody i i don't i
feel like rapping
but at the same time that's what i'm
saying it's like
when you start getting into bars and
quotables and hip-hop
is not just based on that it's based on
everything
it's based on everything it's based on
your presence and all that and like it's
like now bro it's like the nba
i'd be like yo they might as well just
make the nba the christmas game the
all-star game in the playoffs because
nobody plays no more
mm-hmm i know y'all got injuries and
[ __ ] but nobody don't [ __ ] play this
[ __ ] is crazy
and it's like that's how i'm feeling
about hip-hop now it's like people don't
play as much as they used to it's like